>> I'm thrilled to introduce Sharon Meers,
a former managing director at Goldman Sachs
who, together with coauthor Joanna Strober,
has figured out how husbands, wives, and kids
all thrive when couples share equally as breadwinners
and caregivers.
After interviewing hundreds of parents and
employers and doing a great deal of research,
Sharon and Joanna have put together their
book, "Getting to 50/50.”
The book has been an inspiration to me as
a working mom, and I'm grateful to have Sharon
speak here at Google today.
Sharon speaks frequently to professional organizations
about work/life balance issues, a topic that
we value here at Google.
I'll let Sharon tell you the rest.
And now, introducing Sharon Meers.
>> [Clapping]
Sharon Meers: Thanks so much, Stacy.
And thanks to all of you for joining us this
afternoon.
First of all, I have to say, I am particularly
honored to be back here at Google.
Google was, in fact, the site of our very
first booktalk back in March.
And, in fact, many Google employees have been
particularly insightful and thoughtful advisors
to us in the three-plus years it took to research
and pull this book together.
So again, I am very interested in what we're
going to do today, which is really the project
of the book.
Which is to share some information and talk
together about how we might collectively change
the dynamics and the framing of the discussion
on "work and family.”
One of the things that we've found -- we've
now been wandering around the country for
a little over three months, and we've spoken
to probably 2,000 people on corporate campuses
and university campuses.
And one of the fun things for us is, about
half the people who are showing up are guys.
Which sort of reinforces something that we
have had a sense of which is, that men and
women share this concern that we need to evolve
the way we think about work and family so
that men can have the joys of full parenthood
and women can have the joys of full careers.
So, part of the reason we got interested in
writing this book was, we were sensing that
the very nature of the conversation was having
some unintended and negative consequences.
Back in 2004, Joanna and I were speaking at
Stanford Business School at a course called
"Work and Family", taught by a labor economist
there.
And we were both struck by the nature of the
conversation and the nature of the questions
we were getting from students in their late
20's -- students who had signed up aiming
to be leaders of industry, paying hundreds
of thousands of dollars collectively for the
right for those seats so that they could pursue
those careers.
And as they sat in that room thinking how
the work part was going to come together with
the family part, there was an incredible amount
of anxiety.
And you can't blame them.
One, because it's awfully tough.
It's much more tough than it needs to be,
because the world hasn't evolved in the way
many people expected it would.
But the thing that concerned us was, there
was a sense of resignation, as if things might
be impossible.
That it would be necessary to give up on either
a significant portion of career goals or a
significant portion of family goals.
And while we see tradeoffs every day in our
own life, we sense that the level of anxiety
was more a function of the misinformation
out in the world rather than the function
of what we were going to try to do, which
is, improve the flow of communication about
the real facts, the real research, and put
more of a spotlight on the dual-career couples
who actually are figuring this out.
So that we can all think about how this can
help us and apply in our own lives.
To take it back another step, I was asked
to speak at a women's leadership conference
at a very competitive university where a couple
hundred women competed for 40 slots to come
in the week before school started, to hear
from various different leadership coaches.
And I was on a panel and kept getting questions
-- myself, along with the other men and women
on the panel -- we were being asked,
"Well, what if I'm away from my job for two
years? Or seven years? Or five years?”
And I finally looked at the crowd, and I said,
"Wow, can I ask?
How many of you think you are going to want
to leave your job for more than a year when
you have children?”
And I ask all of you, What percentage of hands
went up?
Any guesses? I hear whispers. Anyone venture?
20 percent? 90 percent? 70 percent?
Seventy percent of the kids.
And I said, "Wow. I really, really hope that
can work out for you.”
But so far, in my professional experience,
I don't know of a large number of significant
jobs where you can have a leadership role
and pull out for multiple years at a time.
So those things -- either the world has to
change a lot, or this idea of 'the need to
pull out' needs to change.
So, at any rate, what we'd like to do in engaging
you in this conversation and share what we
learned in our research and then open it up
to a conversation among all of us here.
So, as Stacy mentioned, we did two kinds of
research.
First, we surveyed the social science -- everything
from the research on child development and
child care, research on marriages, research
on the psychological well-being of men and
women, organizational behavior research.
A lot of that is written up in the 50-50 Fact
Sheet you have on your chair, and you can
look up the citations, and happy again to
talk about that in more detail in a few minutes.
But let me come to something that struck us
as most incredible as we read through all
the social science.
It seemed that a great opportunity we have
in reframing this issue is to see a fact,
which is that, Men and women really have more
in common than we have differences as it relates
to work and family.
And, if you look at the surveys, men and women
equally poll as wanting change.
Eighty percent of dads -- for the last couple
decades -- working dads say they want more
time with their kids.
That is at least as high as the percentage
of working moms who say they want time with
kids.
And people think that's because working moms
in general feel they have more license to
walk out and be with their kids, whereas working
dads -- due to cultural norms -- don't feel
that way.
Secondly, according to the National Institute
of Mental Health and a number of other big
research institutes, the idea that our dads
or uncles or husbands or brothers need their
careers more than our sisters and mothers
and female friends is just wrong.
There is not scientific basis for that.
It may feel that way.
That may be the stuff of social lore, but
if you actually look at the factors that predict
long-term mental health and actually long-term
physical health in men, they relate to strong
relationships with family and that the men
who suffer most -- in terms of physical stress
and also mental stress -- are the men who
have allowed the family relationships in their
lives to break down.
So it's an interest for all of us to allow
men to invest in family just as we allow women
to.
So, the other part of our research was going
out and talking to working couples.
We surveyed 1100 working moms, and then we
went and found slightly over 200 men and women
in dual-career homes and asked them how they
did it.
We looked at people in all kinds of jobs in
all different parts of the country.
And three general messages came away for us.
The first is, Mindset makes all the difference.
The way you frame and think about work and
family determines whether it's easy for you
or easier for you or really hard -- and we'll
talk about that in a second.
Secondly, there is a 'game plan', a way of
talking and acting that allows some couples
to negotiate much more fairness in their marriages
without a fight.
This is not, you know, "Who's Afraid of Virginia
Woolf," that movie where the husband and wife
shout at each other the whole time.
This is about finding collegial fun, sometimes
funny ways to talk with each other about stuff
that is typically very emotionally laden -- to
take the emotion out of it so we can get to
happier solutions.
And the third point is that -- when you take
this back to work -- happy working couples
all seem to have some sense that they could
control the norms in their office.
And not all these people were super-senior
executives.
Many of them were mid-level in their career.
But they had some sense that they could innovate
and change their job in some way to give themselves
enough latitude so they could do what they
needed to do for their kids.
We're going to go into each one of those takeaways
in a little more depth.
But let me start first with this question
of "mindset" -- how you think about work and
family drives everything.
And again, all the details behind this section
are embedded in that fact sheet you got.
The first thing we notice in talking to all
these dual-career couples was, they seem uniformly
comfortable with the idea that two working
parents are actually good -- not a necessary
evil, but good.
And that they are good for kids and mothers.
And they're also good for dads and marriage.
So we were very curious as we dug into the
social science.
You know, are they just optimists, or is there
a scientific basis for this?
And it turns out, there is a ton of research
that supports this point of view.
To begin with, kids do equally well whether
their moms work or not.
How many of us knew that?
Certainly not what I read in the newspaper.
But we have the opportunity to talk to the
leading social scientist at the largest universities
in this country who all fed into something
called the NICHD Study of Child Care and Child
Development, the largest-ever study of child
care and child development done in human history.
It wrapped up in 2006.
It sadly had basically a tiny P.R. budget.
So what we read about it in the New York Times
was not very informative at all.
But if you go and talk to the lead researcher
at Harvard who worked on that or at University
of California or at University of Texas or
any of the big places that were involved,
they will tell you the bottom line was, there
is no respected research that says, "Female
employment harms children".
In fact, it may be the opposite.
When they look at the issue of 'Depression
vs. Well-being', there is a mountain of research
that says when any of us pull away from employment
-- when we reduce the number of sources of
self-worth that we have -- we increase our
risk of depression.
Probably fairly intuitive that that would
be the case.
But they have documented what happens to women
-- not only in white-collar professions,
but also in blue-collar jobs -- when they
pull back from the work force, and there's
something like a 30-percent spike in risk
of depression.
And that's been in the psychology literature
for a long time.
Unfortunately, what we've gotten caught up
in are little findings and little studies
about day care.
And that is a legitimate thing to be concerned
about, but not if you are a parent and not
if you're planning to pay attention, which
I would assume everybody in this room does
and plans to do.
So I can talk about that later.
But basically, the thing we came away most
excitingly was this idea that working mothers
-- or working fathers for that matter -- had
anything to feel guilty about.
It just really had no rational basis.
The third point here, though, I think is most
exciting in terms of the idea of men and women
working together as equals, because there
are a number of studies that say, How involved
a dad is, is a function of a mother's attitude
more than a father's attitude.
So there are studies that say, "If you give
men and women opinion/attitude questions,
and you ask, What's maternal instinct?
Do you believe in maternal instinct?
Do you believe men are naturally fit to comfort
infants?
Do you believe that women are more nurturing?
Those sorts of questions.
Women who hold a strong belief that they,
as women, are naturally more able as parents
and nurturers tend to have husbands who help
less.
On the other hand, women who are willing to
believe that husbands are naturally as capable
-- that the raw talent is there, expressed
or not -- those women have husbands who help
more.
And interestingly, they control for questions
like, you know, How conservative is the husband?
And at the end of the day, the driving factor
was what the women believed.
So, how does this all play out for dads and
marriage?
So, the very wonderful thing in bringing men
into the picture of work and family is, the
research says, Men make a huge difference
in outcomes for children.
We spent all this time worrying about 'maternal
involvement', but the swing factor really
appears to be 'paternal involvement'.
There's a lot of stuff in the book about Time
Diary studies, where they've looked at the
difference in time with kids of working moms
vs. nonworking moms.
And it's not a huge difference.
But among fathers, the difference is massive.
And it's mostly sort of cultural -- microcultural.
So the good news is, When dads are actively
involved, they get dramatically better results
for kids, even in two-parent families.
Active fathers are seen as the driving determinant
of things like better grades, more self-confidence,
better behavior -- more so even than moms.
And part of the reason for this again, gets
to this massive difference in the way men
behave.
There's a big Department of Education study
that looked at 20,000 kids.
And they found that -- among married couples
-- 73 percent of fathers went to their child's
school either 'twice a year' to never.
And whereas, you know, among working mothers
it was basically the opposite.
The interesting point was when dads got divorced,
dads acted exactly like divorced mothers who
are almost as involved as married mothers.
So it's not that men's jobs keep them from
going to school.
It's the sense we have that if there is a
mother around, she's taking care of it and
that that's all good.
And what the research says is, It's better
if we can make room for dads.
So the other way this is all useful is, The
effect on marriage are also quite helpful.
When we launched this book in the middle of
the pit of the market crash, this second point
-- that Two career bets are better than one
-- was much less controversial than we thought
it was going to be.
You know, the silver lining of what we've
all been through in the last year is that
it reminds us that, In a world where men and
women really are raised and educated to be
more equal than not, we all have the ability
to be pretty strong engines.
And if you have a choice of flying in a plane
with one engine or two, what are you going
to pick? Particularly in a storm.
It's awfully nice to have another functioning
engine so that, if you get into a spot -- one
spouse doesn't like their boss, they can change,
they can start a company, all those good things.
But then, the fun stuff is really this last
point which is, more sharing equates to both
lower divorce and more sex.
On the divorce side, in 2006, the University
of Chicago Sociology Review published what
was a groundbreaking finding.
And that is that, couples in the United States
who've gotten married since the mid-80's,
of that population, those with the lowest
divorce risk are the couples that most evenly
share earnings and housework.
That was a surprise to a lot of sociologists,
because historically, the belief was that
if a woman earned more money that unhappiness
was evenly distributed among couples.
If a woman earned more money, she could more
easily walk out.
So that, a woman earning more money was thought
to be correlated with higher divorce.
Amazingly, no one bothered to look at the
behavior of men.
And when you actually look at the pools of
government data that also look at how housework
is divided and put that together with the
earnings data, you find that, When husbands
do more around the house whether or not their
wives work, they dramatically cut divorce
risk.
But when you put those two things together,
equal sharing in the housework and in taking
responsibility for paying bills, that seems
to be the most protective of marriage.
But the one factoid that everyone likes the
most -- when I go to largely male crowds,
this gets me the largest guffaws -- and that
is, there are tons of pieces of research from
the child care and child development researchers
to the marriage researchers who have found
that couples who report having the most sex
coincidentally are the couples that report
that the husband does the largest share of
housework.
So these good things go together, no matter
who's working.
So if 50/50 is good for kids, good for marriage,
good for men and women, How do we get more
of it in our lives given that most parts of
society don't set us up to do this successfully?
If we pattern ourselves after the way most
couples work on television -- after our own
parents -- in all likelihood, it is going
to be a little bit challenging to share as
equally as we might want to share ideally.
And there's actually interesting research
-- there's some folks out at Berkeley who,
for the last 30 years have been studying couples.
And they've come to the conclusion that, no
matter how liberal a couple is going into
the process of having children, there is almost
always some backsliding into traditional roles
-- for a whole bunch of reasons we can talk
about -- and it would be fine if everyone
was thrilled about the backsliding into traditional
roles, but unfortunately, it also correlates
with a higher degree of discord in the couple
where people feel misunderstood and shoved
into roles that they didn't intend -- to the
man feeling like he's not getting a lot of
help/support when he feels more pressured
to earn money to pay for a baby, and the wife
feeling like she's not getting enough support
dealing with the grand chaos that is early
childhood.
So here are three things that happy, working
couples told us -- this is based on our interviews,
but also from talking with the big marriage
experts and negotiation experts -- there's
a whole section in our book from the authors
of "Getting to Yes" which you might recall
is a big negotiation classic.
This is all very similar.
And the first thing people told us they did
was, Make a masterplan.
That the big problem people get into is, we
don't treat our home lives with as much respect
as we treat our office lives.
You know, you're having a conflict with the
person in the next office over, and you're
working on a project, you're going to at some
point say, "Hey, I need to sit down with you.
Let's figure out why this isn't working.
Let's take out a piece of paper, a whiteboard,
whatever.
Let's write down what we need to do and how
it's going to happen in a way that we can
work well together.”
It's not that emotional a conversation; you
just do it, because it's for the good of the
project.
And what we heard happy, working couples do
-- more often than not -- was, say, "You
know what?
I was really pissed at you all week.”
Not going to say that.
I'm going to say, "You know, this week didn't
work so well.
Can we go grab a Starbucks and take out a
pad of paper, and let's try to figure out,
What were the three things that went the most
wrong?
And How is that not going to go wrong next
week?”
And they would treat it as a problem-solving
activity.
The second thing was 'letting go'.
You know, when you're sitting there at Starbucks
with your lists -- being willing to throw
aside things that your mother and great aunt
or father might not.
So, you know, my husband -- golf game sometimes
have to go.
With my case -- elaborate kid's birthday parties
sometimes have to go.
And you know, I might emotionally fight, "It's
important.
Our children care.”
And my husband will say, "Really? I think
our son just likes cake." So.
I think that the concept is, We have to be
willing to laugh about it a little bit.
In our Today Show appearance, Joanna brought
up this hysterical conversation we had with
a man who indignantly told us, "My wife thinks
you have to make hospital corners on every
bed in our house every day before we walk
out the door.
It's infuriating.
I don't like doing beds, period.
There are four beds in the house.
And we just want to get our kids off to school
with enough food to eat every day.
And this is just not a good use of time.
Why does it have to be -- why do I have to
accept that that's part of my 'to do' list?”
And we thought about it, and we're like, He's
right, you know?
Why? Why does she get to make that call?
And who would die if the beds weren't made?
Certainly, without hospital corners, no one
would die.
So it's, again, giving men and women equal
votes in the home in the same way we give
men and women equal votes in the office.
And the third point is, I think, we saw a
lot of happy working couples.
They were motivated to share, because it allowed
them to escape this sense of guilt that we
have heard talked about for way too many decades
-- that, if you really know your spouse is
interchangeable with you, it may be hard and
sad to leave your child.
Like last night, I had to leave my daughter
in the middle of the day to get on a plane
to come here.
And she was not happy about it.
She's five.
She was not happy about it until my husband
came up and said, "Hey, let's go for a swim.”
And she's like, "Oh, good-bye.”
And while I did feel bad that she felt bad
that I was leaving, I also knew that she was
now in the hands of a parent she loved as
much as she loves me and was going to go do
something really fun and when we talked on
the phone, it was going to be okay.
But I think very frequently, when we see either
mom and dad as having unique and very different
qualities, it makes it harder to mix things
up that way.
So if we agree that this can be good for families
and it is doable in a constructive way, how
do we bring 50/50 into the workplace?
God knows I have never worked in a particularly
50/50 environment.
I have worked pretty much only in 24/7 environments,
and I know that you all work in something
quite similar.
So one of the questions we had to ask ourselves
-- particularly bringing this book out in
the middle of a recession -- is, How can pro-parent
be pro-profit?
Is there a way of aligning those two values?
And we came to the conclusion that Yes, there
really is.
Because a lot of the research we looked at
comes straight out of the business schools,
and I'm going to share just a few 'thought
experiments' with you.
And you can think about how they might fit
into your lives, but they are just examples
of people doing things dramatically differently
so that workers in high-stress jobs can take
more control of their time.
The first is a case study from Harvard Business
School that shows how much 'more metrics'
can free people up.
In the late 1980s, Lehman Brothers was in
a terrible shape in its research department.
Their research department was ranked number
15 in the industry.
There's a magazine called Institutional Investor,
which is the only barometer of how you're
doing.
And Institutional Investor -- or I.I., as
it was called -- ranked them number 15.
And, you know, you might as well close shop.
And so, they brought up a guy named Jack Rivkin
to turn the research unit around.
And Rivkin was a very unusual guy.
His view was, you know, "I'm not going to
spend a lot of time chatting with all the
analysts and getting to know them and whatever
else.
I'm simply going to give them a list of metrics
that I'm going to measure them on.
And it's not just, How good was your earnings
estimate?
How good was your ebitda estimate? What have
you.
It's also, all the different things that I
think drive being a good analyst.
How many times did you call the CEO?
The CFO? The suppliers? The clients?
The salespeople who represent your research?
The portfolio managers who read your research?
How many special projects did you do for those
portfolio managers?
All these different things that drive performance
in that job, Jack Rivkin was willing to put
on paper and say, "I'm counting for each one
of you how you do.”
And by the way, if you wanted to come and
spend hours schmoozing with me in my office,
that does not count.
At the end of the day, you'll be paid on this
list and only on that.
The result was unbelievably dramatic.
It was dramatic in the sense that they went
from number 15 to number one in three years.
By 1990, they were ranked number one by Institutional
Investor.
Everyone on the team -- the percentage of
analysts who were doing well jumped dramatically.
But the most extraordinary thing was that
the percentage of women who were ranked as
top analysts by Institutional Investor, went
from almost none to 80 percent.
Guys went from 20 percent to 40 percent.
So it was good for everyone, but it was dramatically
good for women.
And the thought -- in these case studies -- is
that it allowed women to A, control their
time and produce what was important, and that
their contributions could be objectively evaluated.
The second thing is, some research on fire
drills and interruptions.
There's a woman named Leslie Perlow, who started
her research at MIT and she's now ended up
as a tenured professor at Harvard Business
School.
And her whole realm of study has been workers
and technology and consulting and investment
banking and trying to understand if there's
a way to rethink how all we white-collar workers
produce excellence.
And one study that she looks at -- she went
to a high-tech firm, and she said, "I want
the name of three, offshore suppliers that
produce exactly the same thing at exactly
the same quality.”
And she ended up with a firm in China, a firm
in India, and a firm in Hungary.
And she sent a team of researchers to go and
observe in each of those places.
And while they were all producing the same
thing at the same level of quality, she found
they all did things differently -- all with
the sense that 'their way' was the 'only way'.
So, the folks in India worked a 14-hour day
on average.
Everybody -- when people had questions -- they'd
go run around and ask each other questions,
because it was part of the culture to, you
know, bond with your peers and exchange information.
Very individualistic.
In China, it was like study hall.
Everybody sat there quietly.
There was a boss and there were the engineers.
And they worked that way for eight hours a
day.
And they were hugely efficient, and they were
producing as much per day as the folks in
India working 14 hours a day.
Go to Hungary.
In Hungary, they had a much more fluid view
of things that the cycle of every project
went up and down and that their work hours
would go up and down like this.
And so, on average, they were working something
like ten hours a day.
But it peaked and troughed based on when deadlines
were.
And there was a lot of sense that you could
actually go home and get more work done from
home.
They had a lot of managers who were very supportive
of that.
So, Perlow's view -- when she was starting
to do a lot of stuff in Harvard Business Review
about this is that, You can go to a big management
consulting firm or an investment bank, places
where this is unthinkable.
Say, You know what?
You think that the only way to produce this
kind of excellence is to be here 24/7 looking
at it.
Well, it's not right, because there are other
people who do it differently and produce work
of quality that is equivalent to yours and
they do it differently and they allow people
not to blow up their lives.
So there is going to be, I think, a lot more
of that coming up in the business journals
in the next couple of years.
The last piece I'll talk about is sort of
'microgood process'.
There was a woman we interviewed who had been
at Sullivan and Cromwell as an associate.
And she had been offered a partnership role
in a boutique securities litigation firm.
And when she went to court the first day as
the junior partner watching her senior partners,
she was shocked, because the judge -- at the
end of the day -- turned to her new senior
partner and said, "Hey, I need you to file
this by tomorrow morning.”
And her new senior partner said, "Your Honor,
we really aren't staffed for that.
Can you give us three days?”
And the judge said, "Sure.”
And this young woman from Sullivan and Cromwell
said she almost fell over.
If she had tried to pull a stunt like that
representing Sullivan and Cromwell, you would
have been shot, because that's just not the
image Sullivan and Cromwell wants to have.
You say, "Yes, sir.”
When somebody -- a judge -- tells you to turn
something in the next morning.
You are not given the sense that you have
the latitude to say,
"Why? Why tomorrow morning? Why not in three
days?”
But the material difference is, at her new
firm, they do not need to run associates ragged
-- from time to time they do -- but they
are much more thoughtful about when a deadline
is truly 'overnight,' and when work can be
spaced out in a more thoughtful way.
So I just throw that out to you.
So I'll just close with this.
This quote, "Every male CEO should have a
working wife." was spoken by a former colleague
of mine, Abby Joseph Cohen, at Goldman Sachs.
And it was spoken, I believe, in about 1996.
And at the time, I was a young V.P. at Goldman,
and I was very inspired by, "What a nice thing.
Let's imagine the day when every male CEO
has a working wife.”
And I'm afraid we're not that much closer
to it today, 13 years later.
So, while I believe she is correct that one
of the things that needs to happen is that
more people who get to make decisions about
how we all work need to get what dual-career
life is about.
But in the meantime we have lives to lead,
careers to succeed in, children to raise happily,
and what are we going to do?
And we come away thinking about three things.
First is, finding 50/50 friends and colleagues.
All of the sociology research says it's so
much easier to live the way you want if you
have a buddy system.
If you can find -- not everybody has to be
just like you -- but you can find other people
who support the way you live and help you
stand against norms that are unhelpful to
your living the way you want to live.
Secondly, knowing it's not 50/50 every day.
It's 60/40 or 90/10.
That's not really the point, the actual split
of, you know, who does the dishes and the
laundry and the kid pick-up.
It's really a mindset that says, "Dads need
their kids, and women need their jobs and
over the course of life that should work out.”
And we think the more that people -- all of
us -- change the dialogue about work and family
and talk about these things, and about the
real facts about dual-career families, the
more we will help people see that we can share
the load between men and women and we can
change the way we work, and that will change
the world.
So with that, I am very eager to hear what
your thoughts are. Thank you.
>> [Clapping]
>> [pause]
Sharon Meers: Anybody? Thank you.
Q First, thank you for coming.
And I'm sure my question is probably somewhere
in the book, but one thing that my husband
and I do is we keep 'scoreboard'.
And we always try to keep each other from
doing this, where every weekend it's, "Well,
how many diapers have you changed?" and, "Who
did the grocery shopping?”
Are there any tips that you picked up from
working parents, especially the time -- whether
it's at night or on the weekends -- how to
keep from going into scoreboard?
Sharon Meers: How old are your kids?
Q Two. One kid -- two years old.
Sharon Meers: Okay. So one thing I jokingly
say is, when our second child turned three,
I told my husband I thought we had rounded
the tip of Tierra del Fuego -- you know, that
very nasty part of South America where like,
boats crashed into the side of the cliffs
and things like that?
I think early parenthood is just exhausting.
There's just way, way, way too much to do.
And so, the survival of that period is -- I
think what's very helpful to keep in mind
is it's, in the terms of a lifetime, it's
short.
So it will end.
And then it gets a lot easier.
Q Good to know.
Sharon Meers: But, that said, people said
a couple of things.
So I will tell you, with my husband and I
when our kids were really young, we truly
had a "Two hours you. Two hours me. Two hours
you. Two hours me.”
Because we felt it was just the right thing
for our sanity.
Like, we could be great with our kids for
a period of time and, you know, maybe at Hour
Four we were still as cheery as at Hour Five,
but typically, if we could switch off, the
kids would get an up, happy, rested person.
And then we could go do our work or we could
go lie down or we could read a book, you know,
in our times off. So that helped.
You know, in the book, we do talk about a
two-lawyer couple that actually had what they
called the "Waking Hours Spreadsheet.”
And it was more -- I think you can have a
sense of humor about it.
Your scoreboarding is not terrible, because,
you know, it is again, a period of a couple
years where you are just being pummeled by
the amount of work there is to do.
The other thing to think about is, we periodically
go through 'triage' weekends.
"We are dying.
What is on our list that has got to go?
Like, what thing are we just going to agree
we're just not doing?”
So, one thing that's happened in our house
-- I recently discovered we had something
like five photo albums that had either been
given to us or we had purchased since having
children.
They are all empty.
We have umpteen Kodak Gallery O Photo accounts.
And I think we have just come -- we have explicitly
come to the agreement that, when our children
are tweeners and they can help, we'll do it
together.
Between now and then, just forget about it.
But, I think, you know, everybody -- for all
of us -- there are little things that sort
of nag at us, "Got to do this. Got to do this.”
And just ask yourself, What would happen if
you didn't do it?
What would happen if you didn't do it?
Because I think it's all about reducing the
level of stress, which is a function of having
this enormously long list of things that feel
like they have to happen.
Q It's really helpful to just hear that it
gets easier.
And I'm seeing, as he gets more independent,
that it's getting easier.
But it comes with a whole other side of things
that have to get done.
But thank you, that was helpful.
Sharon Meers: Thank you.
Q I have a question.
First of all, thanks for being here.
And it's a great lecture.
Well, I have a technical question, a "what
if" scenario.
So, what if the wife is more successful at
career, should the husband feel more pressure
to get ahead -- work harder to get promoted
-- or should he spend more time at home like,
do more housework?
>> [laughter]
Sharon Meers: So, you know, obviously every
couple is different, so they'll look at this
differently.
So, you know, my husband and I had a lot of
conversations about this when we were dating.
And I think, you know, it's my view that we
are lucky enough to live in a time when husbands
and wives really do have access to great jobs.
It's not a perfect world yet, but we have
access to good jobs.
So women actually -- in a world where things
are fair, if a husband and wife go into the
same job, kind of 50-50 chance she's going
to do better, right?
And you know, there is some statistic that
says a third of women in married couples earn
more than their husbands, which is dramatically
different than 20 years ago.
But I think the way we looked at it is, long-term,
who knows, right?
She can invest her career in a fabulous company
that, you know, turns out to be Enron or Merrill
Lynch or a company that disappears.
So it's awfully helpful for both members of
a couple to maintain their market-readiness
because you just don't know.
It's a marathon; it's not a sprint.
And so, I think what we found in talking to
couples was, there certainly were times when
one person's career was going better.
And, you know, I think there is social pressure
for men if their wives' careers are going
better.
There are all sorts of weird vibes that can
sometimes happen.
And if men can rise above that and say, "Hey,
this is great.
And I can help out more now.
And oh, by the way, I have ambitions too.
There are other things that I want to do with
my life.
And maybe there's not enough space and, you
know, enough time for me to do them now, but
How about in three years or five years or
seven years, you know?”
One of the couples that I liked the most in
the book were two doctors.
And they very explicitly talked about 'baton
passing', where she came out of medical school.
She started into a job working three days
a week.
And he had a very big job, ultimately led
part of a hospital.
And after seven years, he was totally burned
out.
He felt he wasn't getting to see his kids.
And she was chomping at the bit, saying that
she wasn't using her training in the way that
she wanted to.
And she came back full-time.
He scaled back to 80 percent time, though
retaining his role as head of this piece of
the hospital.
And she then became head of internal medicine
at a very large hospital.
So she's now working seventy hours a week
-- a little different than three days a week
-- and he's doing much more around the house.
But the idea is that, over time, they'll go
back and forth, and allow each other to keep
growing.
Does that get to what you are talking about?
Q Yeah. Thanks.
>> [pause]
Q Hi. Thank you for coming.
This is definitely helpful.
I think part of what my husband and I struggle
with the whole thing is not having family
around.
And I'm not sure if you're going to talk about
-- if the book talks a little about it.
Just having that, aside from like friends,
nothing is like family where you can kind
of disconnect, take time out with your husband
and kind of like, "Okay, let's learn what
made us fall in love.”
My sister was telling me the other day -- she
was like, "Oh, I'm so in love with this guy
that I'm going to marry.
Go back to you guys, when you used to date.”
And I'm just like, "What?”
I just laugh about it.
I'm like, "I don't even want to think about
that."
But how much of family and having that closer
network of support was important on the interviews
you had?
Sharon Meers: So I think it is really important.
That said, I think family can have two different
aspects.
But I think the thing that's important is
support.
And support so that you have enough time with
your spouse and you don't feel you are so
overwhelmed that you can't remember what it
was like in the first place. [laughter]
It's very easy to forget.
The trick is sort of, you know, trying to
again, offload as much of the friction, the
stress, and giving yourself as much time as
possible.
And I'll just tell you a funny story.
So my sister has just had her -- her second
child is now 13 months old -- and I was getting
very worried.
She's just one of these very-focused moms,
and she works full-time, and she just didn't
appear to be sleeping at all, to me.
And so, I was telling Joanna, my coauthor,
about this.
And I said, "You know I think I need to take
Kira away to get a weekend.
She just needs to sleep.”
And Joanna looks at me and she says, "Your
sister does not need a romantic weekend away
with you. [laughter] She needs a romantic
weekend away with her husband.”
So my kids and I designed this, you know,
camp for our cousins, which was a tremendous
amount of fun.
Now, we don't live close together.
She lives in L.A.; I live in the Bay Area.
But she and her husband were game and they
came and they dropped the kids and they got
to go wander around in Napa and have a nice
weekend.
And so, I think you have to be -- it's harder
when your family isn't there.
And so, I mean, my mom very nicely sometimes
comes out look after the kids.
Sometimes we leave the kids in D.C. where
she is.
You know, in the book, we have couples who
had their parents literally move in with them
from out of the country while the kids were
very young.
And they talk about, "Well, yes, that was
very nice, because they got to sleep.”
There were also challenges of basically going
back to your family of origin with that much
closeness.
The other thing people talk about was, in
effect, coming up with 'pseudofamily'.
Coming up with a bunch of other parents who
have kids exactly the same age whose parenting
values you agree with.
So that it doesn't work very well when your
kid is one, but when they're four, they can
have sleepover at the Jones'.
Then the other parents can actually have a
little bit of rest.
But it does come up and it's challenging and
there are alternatives.
Q But it will get better.
Sharon Meers: But it will get better. How
old are yours?
Q Two.
Sharon Meers: Two. Yes. Age three -- 36 months.
It's coming.
Q Thank you.
>> [pause]
Q Can you talk a little bit about your views
about -- there seems to be a contrast between
this two-engine view vs. the two-income trap.
Sharon Meers: So I have to say I'm quite befuddled
by this two-income trap concept.
Because as I understand it, it's this idea
that somehow two very bright people could
get themselves into a situation where they
are spending a lot of money and then one person
decides they don't want to work and then,
they can't stop spending that money?
And I'm just confused. I'm just confused.
I think if we are rational people, you know,
what I think we talk about a lot in the book
is coming to peace with and learning to talk
about these decisions early and often and
honestly.
Because I think if you do, you don't end up
in situations like that.
So, you know, a lot of times the research
says that something like 84 percent of women
who leave white-collar jobs don't really mean
to leave them.
They don't leave because they want to.
They leave either because they have a misunderstanding
with a direct boss who may have a very flexible
policy but refuses to implement it or implements
it in a way that feels alienating to the woman,
so she leaves.
Or they have a spouse who somehow conveys
the idea -- or she accepts the idea -- that
his career is more important regardless of
whether or not he makes more money.
Because of this belief that we talked about
in the beginning that somehow careers matter
more to men than to women.
So if you haven't thought about that to begin
with and you've built up a very expensive
lifestyle, and then bing! You say, "Oh, my
God! I'm supposed to be home with my children,
because I read X -- Dr. Laura's -- as I'm
supposed to." you're going to have a problem.
But I still don't find it so difficult for
people to de-leverage, right?
If you're a sensible person, you can sell
the house.
You can pay down the debt. You can do all
these things.
But I think it's all much easier if you think
about it in the beginning, because my perspective
is, There's really no reason if you want to
work, there's no reason you can't do it.
Am I answering your question, or not really?
Q Yeah. I mean, I don't think there's a right
answer.
In one case, you have one person making all
the money with none of these benefits, but
there's only one point of failure there.
And in the other case, you have two people
making money, but that's two points of failure.
That's sort of redundancy, but then you have
to readjust and I don't know.
It doesn't seem like there's a right answer.
But I think you're right.
You just basically have to do your planning
well and are willing to be flexible when things
change then that seems like the best that
you can do.
Thanks.
Sharon Meers: That's good.
Q Thank you for coming.
That was sort of similar to my question.
So along this same vein, I've seen a lot of
-- more so friends; we're very fortunate
at Google so less colleagues -- you know,
that both people achieve all this advanced
education and do all these things and then
get to the point where, from a practical standpoint
-- in particular, I think living in places
like the Bay Area or New York or more expensive
living areas where there's a breakdown, not
so much in maybe the communication between
the couple, but in that, "Okay, if we're going
to have a nanny.
How are we accommodating all these things
that there seems to be a point at which, Does
this actually make sense for two people to
be working when, This is how much time we're
going to have with our children, and This
is how much time we're going to be working
and then, you know, When we break out the
excel, this is how much money we can put in
savings, and things of that nature.”
So I was wondering if you could just expand
a little bit more on -- from a practical standpoint
in terms of, you know, whether it's positioning
sort of like you said 'passing the baton'
in terms of maybe working three days a week
or just different strategies perhaps that
you had learned from interviews about, you
know, ways to approach sort of in those early
years and still being able to have both partners
working?
Sharon Meers: So, yeah, great questions.
In the middle section of the book, we have
a chapter called, "Women want to work.
Women don't leave because they want to.”
And there's a whole array of examples of women
in demanding jobs who change the nature of
them.
A woman who runs part of engineering at a
big tech firm who works at home a number of
days a week for the last 12 years.
You know, people who do all sorts of creative
and different things.
But the first thing I want to get to is this
business about the economics calculation in
child care.
Because a lot of people we interviewed have
been like, you know, have been surprised when
we say this.
But if you actually do do the math, and you
are willing to look at anything beyond the
first five years, it makes no sense for anyone
to quit period, right?
Because, like even if you start at a fairly
low level, the power of compounding over a
30-year career is pretty big.
And so, it overwhelms child care cost.
And then, beyond that, people say, "Well,
how do you survive the short-term child care
costs?”
And that's really, I think, about being open-minded.
And it's everything from -- you know, there's
a couple in our book who also worked at a
high-tech company and they were both doing
very well.
They asked to job share.
So they, husband and wife shared one job.
So they each worked three days a week.
And the day that they were both at work, his
dad, who had moved to be with them, looked
after the child.
So they had no child care, period, right?
So that was an expensive 'zero'.
There's a two-teacher couple who arranged
their schedule with the principal so they
could hand off a child in the hallways. Not
joking.
So there are people who do really inventive
things.
I'm sure we all have friends who are in less
well-compensated professions where they, in
effect, group -- they have a group babysitter.
Somebody finds a really talented person.
They don't want the whole expense.
They bring in one or two other children so
that, you know, you have -- or reduce by two-thirds
-- the hourly cost.
So there really are ways of getting that cost
under control if you are willing to see it
as a worthy enterprise to be innovative about.
I think people get very emotional -- we are
too fast to just switch it off and say,
"It's too hard. It's too hard. Give it up.”
Mostly because we believe the Dr. Laura arguments
that somehow it would be better if mom were
at home.
And we don't look at what the research really
says.
And so, if we do know what the research really
says, then it's much easier to say, "Oh, I
should spend a little bit more time over here
being inventive about, you know, How are we
going to come up with a situation we feel
comfortable with that's cost-effective for
us and How are we going to look ahead and
say, "Oh yeah, in ten years we're going to
be miles ahead of where we would be if one
of us completely stepped out.”
But to your question -- our argument is that
we just want both men and women to feel they
can keep a toe in while they have little kids,
because to knock all these smart people out
of the work force is crazy.
It's crazy given all the educational dollars
that go into all of us.
It doesn't make any sense.
So how do you keep these people, you know,
continuing to build their skills, if at a
slower rate?
And we talk about a lot of companies -- even
law firms -- that have kind of pushed themselves
to get outside their normal frame.
Like, there's a guy who runs managing partner
of a very large law firm.
And he said he went into a partner meeting
to talk about -- they had like five different
failed, part-time programs.
And everyone's like, "Ugh, part-time, ugh.”
Whining women. They quit. "Ugh.”
So they said, "Okay, it's not 'part-time.'
It's called 'modified hours'.”
And some partner says, "I need every associate
working 150 percent on every matter I have.”
And the managing partner said, "That is just
baloney.
You have no associate working 150 percent
on anything.
Because every associate here is at least on
four matters.
So, at best, you got 25 percent.
So, what do you care if the other 75 percent
or 25 percent is spent at home?
You should not care.
All you care about is that the time you have
the associate, they're really, really good.
And so, a lot of it gets to sort of, you know,
not just workers changing the way we think,
but managers sort of getting out of this sort
of anti-communist mindset that we have that
makes it really hard to innovate and come
up with creative solutions.
Q Thank you so much.
Sharon Meers: You're very welcome.
Q It seemed to me that, at one point, you
were kind of -- you were implying that there's
a lot of value in having equivalent income
of the husband and wife.
My wife's a preschool teacher and she always
wants to work with the children.
And this is what she really enjoys.
There's no way that she'll ever make even
a third of what I make.
So, how important is it that husband/wife
make the same kind of money?
How do I come to a 50/50 agreement with my
wife in this kind of circumstance?
Sharon Meers: So let me explain.
So the study that I was talking about, you
know, is -- that's just sort of one of the
data points in the study.
And the thing that was more important was
the husband contributing more equally to the
housework.
That was actually -- that was a bigger deal
than equivalence of income.
And what the marriage research really says,
it's about having mutual respect, which is
easier when you can both have a sense of what
the other person's up against.
So if you have some sense of what it's like
for her to go and teach every day and not
get paid that much for it, it's easier for
you to support her in that.
It's easier for her to support you in long
hours at Google when she has a keen sense
of what that's like. You know that.
So I think what the marriage research says
really -- more than anything else -- is that,
If we can throw aside this idea that men's
careers come first and that, no matter what
a person earns, it is important for them to
be involved in something outside their family.
That that's what the psych research says.
And oh, by the way, it's important for both
parents to be engaged with their children.
Then, you can sort of mix it up.
But we interviewed a lot of people where the
husband was in business or a big lawyer or
whatever it was, and had a wife who was a
teacher or a professor or worked in nonprofit,
and had them talk about why their wife's career
was valuable to them.
You know, what it brought to the marriage
that she was doing stuff that they thought
was valuable.
And just sort of one of the funny stories
that I love.
We were at a panel and one of the people on
the panel was talking about how her stepdaughter
was a public school teacher and that she quote/unquote
had to quit, because her income did not cover
child care.
And the woman sitting next to her was a technology
executive with three children, and she just
started laughing.
And she said, "My husband teaches at a private
school.
I guarantee he makes less than your stepdaughter
working at a public school.
Can you imagine if I went home and said, "Sweetheart,
you don't make enough for our child care.
Have you thought about quitting?”
That just isn't going to happen, right?
We're much more logical when we think about
men and the value of their careers than we
are when we think about women and the value
of their careers.
And so, one of the things -- and we kept -- a
feeling was, Why can't we be more logical
when we look at women and the value of their
careers?
[pause] Anybody else? Thanks very much.
>> [Clapping]